ladies and gentlemen it's spider-man's
birthday today happy birthday peter
parker and happy birthday megan alba and
happy birthday stephen alba that's right
my sister and dad share the same
birthday as peter parker they're
variants within the spider verse now
that i got the stamp of approval from
canadian lad we are going to watch today
i watch spider-man far from home in 0.25
speed and here's what i found this is
actually a follow-up video because he
did one a while ago that i i've seen
pretty much most of canadian lands
videos on my own time already but he put
this up just yesterday since it's
spider-man's birthday we gotta cover
something spider-man related so thank
you so much canadian lad for all the
work you do thanks for your stamp of
approval let's get into this
[Music]
what the hell are you showing me
[Music]
is that this one fake trailers okay
all right
this looks really real
you're gonna get us all killed
[Music]
today i've watched spiderman fur from
home at point 2 fabric speed and found
14 new details that you'll find nowhere
else awesome now this is my second time
watching this movie at 0.2 fabric speed
if you haven't watched my previous
breakdown yet i'd suggest you watch that
after you're done with this one trust me
the details i'm about to show you will
increase your love for marvel films 10
times more than before so without any
further ado let's begin number one at
the beginning of the film aunt may
brought spider-man to this charity event
to raise money for the homeless now if
you have seen some behind-the-scenes
footage you already know that tom
holland wasn't wearing any spider-man
suit during this scene he was in a
motion capture suit because the iron
spider suit that we saw in the movie is
just too good to exist in real life so
they had to cgi the whole suit in the
movie so why am i saying all this notice
in this event people were recording
spiderman in their cell phone because
it's the first time they've ever come
this close to a superhero this is quite
normal for today's standard but notice
the bfx team's attention to detail is so
incredible that they didn't even forget
oh how neat cgi emotion kept your suit
into a spiderman suit but the vfx team
made sure he appears the same way even
in the cell phones that the extras are
carrying in this scene it's things like
that why you gotta subscribe to canadian
land never would have noticed that in a
million years i love how much like
attention to detail canadian lag
constantly gives to the production
design for any of these movies or
anything he's covering because yeah that
is a detail that could have easily been
overlooked but yeah good good good eye
there good eye you can notice a lot when
you're watching things in ridiculous
we have already seen a mistake like this
happening in one division which could
have easily happened here too but thanks
to the vfx department for their
attention to detail number 2 when peter
was preparing for a school trip to
venice aunt may came to his room
so sorry
notice peter has literally taped the
switch on the wall along with the note
that says do not turn off because
turning the switch off would stop his
iron spider suit from charging he even
taped all the plugs so that aunt may
doesn't unplug them number three when
peter arrives in venice he goes to buy
the black dahlia necklace for mj which
he had already planned to give her as a
gift in the beginning of the film i'm
gonna buy her a black dahlia necklace
because her favorite flower is the black
dahlia because of well the murder the
murder you notice you can actually spot
quentin back aka mysterio in the
background nobody actually noticed it
until jake gyllenhaal himself reveals
the sister wreck on instagram you
certainly cannot see him clear enough
without slowing down this speed it's
incredible how quentin beck was
essentially following peter parker
everywhere he goes just so he can trick
him at the end number four peter denies
nick fury's request to go to prague to
fight the fire elemental because he has
to go to paris the next day with his
classmates as a result nick fury
hijacked peter's summer vacation and
changed the destination from paris to
prague we're going to prague huh
what and notice peter and ned always end
their handshake routine very smoothly
but hearing the shocking news they both
ended up pulling the wrong move
actually goes wrong
i wonder if that was a moment between
the actors of just improvising and
feeling it in the moment if there was
actually a specific direction on john
watts because i love the littlest
attention to detail like that when it
comes to rehearsal or anything with
actors involved that's a really like
it's the even little details like that
i'm very much fond of number five at
this point we're all familiar with this
scene where peter and quentin have a
conversation by the balcony now keep in
mind mysterio actually can't fly so
whatever peter is seeing here is an
illusion therefore mysterio appeared
with his helmet but notice as soon as
the hologram of mysterio lands beside
peter peter senses something weird i
didn't think i was gonna have to save
the world this summer
notice the way the camera focuses only
on peter this is to prevent us from
seeing the real quentin back sneaking up
behind peter and sitting exactly where
the hologram will land peter's spidey
sense wasn't up to its full potential
yet and that's why he did feel something
but wasn't sure about it number six wait
a minute how did how then did how did
beck get in there how did you have sneak
on in there yeah cause did he come in
from behind if he can't actually fly
yeah yeah or is he on top of the statue
or something because i get what he's
saying if anything that that's more of a
little hole than spider-man yeah i mean
it certainly drives a lot of mystery
around how mysterio is there and where
the illusion ends
back because you would know that
spider-man is on top hate chilling on
the roof there quinn would have to be
somewhere specifically there in order to
seamlessly it's like a swipe cut it's
like a hidden cut in a movie you know
like he would have to seamlessly go with
the hologram in order to do it would he
yeah like project it on top of his body
or something because i like the
attention to detail you're pointing out
in terms of like having tom holland look
to his right at the same time it's
raising this whole other question of
wait how did how did quinton pull that
off exactly number six while everyone
was looking away at the supposed baby
mountain goats we get a shot for less
than a second where mj is clearly
looking at peter parker and discovering
his alter identity in the next shot you
can clearly see she's still looking at
peter this is really hard to notice
without slowing down
that's why right after getting up the
bus mj kept staring at peter oh that is
a really neat attention detail right
there because yeah you can see the
lights of her eyes like clearly oh yeah
she is not taking her eyes off of him at
all no oh that is hilarious i mean she's
a shrewd character it's absolutely
fitting i thought she was just
thought she was just smarter than
everyone else now she's just crushing
and she's lost in peter's eyes slash
edith number seven now this one is one
of my favorites we know how brad caught
peter in a tricky position with this
woman who was only here to give peter
his new style suit brad then took a
picture and decided to show it to mj so
that peter can never get his chances
with her but then of course with the
help of edith peter managed to remove
this photo from brad's device now we all
know that but here's the new detail when
mr harrington was telling the students
they're all gonna go to the opera
everyone showed their frustration with
this decision but notice brad just kept
scrolling
down he's still trying to figure out
where that photo went in fact he even
gives peter an evil look right in the
middle of the scene i'm pretty sure none
of you lads noticed it because the scene
was heavily focused on mr harrington ned
and peter number eight as we know this
black suit is called the stealth suit
now i love the way marvel introduced
this suit for the first time notice we
couldn't really spot where peter is in
this frame until the fireworks started
in the background so with this one
clever shot marvel basically showed us
what the stealth suit is really for
number nine when petersburg were having
a conversation in the bar peter was
being so careless that he literally
forgot the eat of glasses on the floor
put it on here oh my god thank you so
much everybody's on the floor
this woman who just handed peter the
eated glasses was also a member of bag's
team so she simply could have just kept
the glasses and later give it to quentin
beck but she didn't because stealing the
glasses was never a part of the plan
quentin planted the idea on peter's head
to give away edith
that's why this lady handed them that
just goes
to solidify the choice look at the
glasses from peter and put it on the
floor in the first place so that when
she gives it back peter feels ashamed
and irresponsible oh that is a really
great character beat because that is a
hotly debated moment would peter parker
actually
give that up like he barely really knows
quentin back and i've heard a lot of
people argue about that specific choice
to hand over the glasses for a subtle
moment such as that because one thing
that this video alone has been showing
me is kind of like what i've heard
spielberg talk a lot about not that i
would put john watson's philippines on
the same calendar right there there's a
lot going on there's a lot of story
happening even within the background of
things more than just what the audience
is meant to pay solely attention to if
the glasses are on the ground that could
be an indicator that for someone like
peter parker young like maybe i'm not
responsible enough for this that i would
just leave the most dangerous thing here
just let it slip out of the hand and
then
having that dialogue exchange after that
oh that's fascinating yeah well and even
the prospect that maybe she even
pickpocketed them and then orchestrated
that whole exchange it's still like it
yeah it makes that psychological turn
for peter that much stronger to me true
yeah because it plays totally on his
sense of responsibility number 10 when
peter looks up flash's instagram account
to find out where they are we can see
flash's instagram handle which is spidey
number one fan also notice the comments
on his screen none of his comments are
related to flash or his stream meaning
these comments are from box how does he
get certain followers they're all bots
number 11. in the final battle of the
film peter runs out of his website in
his newly designed suit this is probably
because this new suit doesn't have web
shooter refills like his previous suit
used to have number twelve oh and
credits show her mysterio models his
costume based on thor doctor strange and
black panther number 13 in captain
america civil war the audience is silent
during tony stark's birth presentation
binaurally augmented retro framing or
barf
but in the flashback to that same scene
in spider-man from home the audience is
now laughing binaurally augmented retro
framing or barf
this indicates that mysterio remembers
this moment as a lot more humiliating
than it actually was thanks to a user
from reddit this is an awesome piece of
detail number 14. dealing with
perspective the fake mysterio tries to
hand over the eat of glasses to peter
parker while the real mysterio was
trying to shoot peter you notice this
holographic mysterio was holding the
edith glasses as if he's holding and
aiming a gun this was so included
that's a great visual details
speed i hope he does do it like that
yeah that is true before if i did then
please give me a thumbs up though grab
the subscribe button and turn it do it
guys can't wait for this one that i
ignored because i covered them already
in my previous breakdown so please make
sure to watch that too follow me on
instagram and twitter to get updates
about my videos till then i'm dave
chappelle and i'll see you lads in the
next one
way to go dave chappelle
that was fantastic hey plus
nice to meet you
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this i don't think the shot works
did you know that
all right guys so canadian lad be sure
to subscribe to him today he's grown so
much and rightfully so link in the
description box and pin comment happy
spider-man day tell us guys in the
comments what's your favorite detail
from here who's your favorite spider-man
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button keep a lookout for
what if reactions starting up tomorrow
we'll see you guys soon